in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Chuck
and Becky are with us hey guys how are
you doing great
welcome welcome where you guys from
Oxford Ohio near Cincinnati it very fun
cool well it's not too bad a drive to
Nashville but thanks for coming down to
see us so you guys are here to do your
debt-free scream yes I love it how much
have you paid off three hundred and
ninety eight thousand dollars Wow
amazing how long did that take eighty
four months cool something like seven
years okay fun and a range of income
during that time started about 140 and
ended up about 150 excellent what do you
guys do for a living we're teachers I
teach first grade Chuck teaches college
Oh fun good for you guys that's
excellent and who are the young people
with you I was showing Miz's your kids
yes yes ages and names this is Lauren
she's 15 and Daniel he's 12 all right
well welcome guys good to have y'all so
398,000 what kind of debt was this well
we hid for a long time dreamed of owning
some land and the farm right next door
to us came up for sale we had paid off
our house about a year prior and the 398
was for the farm we'd planned on buying
something down the road but farms don't
come up often and they don't come up
often right next door to you yeah really
how big a farm how many acres about 40
Wow very nice very nice so you bought
that and then seven years later you own
it yes indeed I love it well
congratulations so is that what puts you
on the journey to being debt-free is
like okay we're dead free but now we got
the farm now we got to pay that off is
that the story or tell me what happened
no I teach math mm-hm and I understand
what interest does for you and does
against you mm-hmm and when we talked
about buying the farm one of the things
that we decided before we bought it was
we're not going to let it run a 30-year
mortgage because it just costs too much
money oh yeah and we didn't want to be
80 years old still paying a mortgage a
man so we did everything but sell the
kids and
paid it off I love it I love it
well will you maybe used to have three I
don't know but we have ultimate what
makes you think you're our first kid
this is always a possibility of things
get rough oh my gosh well
congratulations you guys so uh what do
you tell people when they find out that
everything is paid for I mean I'm
looking at weird people here y'all are
weird
well yeah our friends say that what do
you tell them the secret to getting out
of debt is perseverance mm-hmm you know
we've we've more than once had to make
decisions on do we want to do this or
not
mm-hmm and we've just kept at it and
even things like Christmas money and
that kind of stuff have gone against the
death and everything that we can has
gone against it because we didn't want
our legacy to be here's a farm and oh
here's the mortgage finish it off yeah
you know that's not much of a legacy a
lot of people do that though sadly well
you got a beautiful place that's amazing
40 acres plus the house you already had
how many acres were with the place she
already had three
okay so 43 you're sitting on that's
wonderful that's fun
well congratulations what was the
hardest part of this journey for you all
so the hardest part was the day leanness
of it we're very different personalities
I'm the people person oriented free
spirit and he's the logical sequential
mrs. Matthews the members absolutely yes
stuff in the pocket even of the shirt
yes yes certified yeah so when different
things would come up and I would make an
assumption it was very different than
the type of assumption he would make so
amazingly we're still married we haven't
killed each other and I'm here we are
what was the do you remember the biggest
fight during the seven years biggest
fight when I overspend when one of you
had an assumption yeah either there
haven't been any big ones because we did
have a spreadsheet like you had a
spreadsheet
he would show me the spreadsheet and I
would say no let's go to the pencil
paper and just have a conversation ah
that's the day leanness of it okay you
know I got you that makes sense all
right
that's fine well I appreciate you all
being real that's that's perfect very
well done
all right it's Chuck and Becky Lauren
and Daniel from the Cincinnati Ohio area
sitting proud on 43 paid-for acres baby
yeah 398,000 paid off in 84 months
making 140 to 150 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
we're debt-free way to go you guys
way to go very proud of you man that's
awesome it's got a great feeling that
place is paid for changes everything
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income on a $500,000 in economy
you